i want to start today with the haitian
immigration crisis uh this is
potentially one of the first major joe
biden
tests
that is sort of going aimlessly and
contributing to joe biden's declining
approval rating we talked about joe
biden needs a big accomplishment
to stem the decline in his approval
rating
the situation with haitian immigrants
does not seem to be helping so we're
going to go through it and i think you
know it's
there's this unfortunate thing where
every time i say hey guys is biden
dropping the ball here people angrily
email me and they say david have you
become some kind of right-wing trumpist
or whatever
presidents mishandle things and it
doesn't mean that i would prefer donald
trump to be president of the united
states just sometimes
presidents don't immediately or at all
handle situations correctly and i think
this is one of those situations where
due to its complexity and due to
conflicting messaging from the current
administration uh it is hurting joe
biden and we can talk about to what
degree that's fair so let's start with
some of the latest news here
reuters reporting angry scenes at haiti
airport add to biden pressure over
expulsions and we'll talk about what
that means in a second
angry scenes broke out at haiti's main
airport on tuesday among migrants set
home from a squalid texas border camp as
u.s president joe biden faced mounting
pressure to stop an expulsion's policy
the u.n refugee refugee chief said it
may be illegal nearly ten thousand
migrants mainly haitian remain in
worsening conditions in the impromptu
camp that sprung up under a bridge
spanning the as it's called in the in
the us the rio grande from the texas
town del rio to mexico to that acuna in
recent days u.s authorities have removed
at least 4 000 people from the site for
processing and detention centers
some 523 haitians have been deported to
their homeland on four flights with
repatriation set to continue on a
regular basis according to dhs
returnees reacted angrily as they
stepped off flights at port-au-prince
airport after spending thousands of
dollars on arduous voyages from the
troubled caribbean nation via south
america hoping for a better life in the
united states on tuesday they found
themselves back where they started a
group of men in white t-shirts rushed
back toward the plane after they
disembarked with one man attempting to
get back on board witnesses said
the migrants broke into a restricted
area of the airport as they attempted to
recover passports and personal
belongings ground staff closed the door
of the plane
before the man could scale the steps
back in tempers ran high exacerbated by
the news the haitian government had
accepted the deportations so there's um
there's an an okay article in politico
outlining the potentially problematic
future of this for joe biden now before
we look at the article i think it's
important to mention
part of the problem here
is that this is a very complicated
situation and you simultaneously have
gensake saying the treatment of the
migrants is unacceptable
um
and you have deportations but they're
saying well the people being deported
are basically just the men but the women
and children are staying and
conservatives are angry either way so
i'm not pretending that there is
objectively a correct solution here that
would absolve joe biden of any drag on
his approval
but we can still acknowledge that this
is causing a problem for joe biden the
politico article
says biden slips into political
quicksand amid haitian migrant buildup
the articles by natasha karecki and
laura baron lopez and the article says
the mass of thousands of haitians at the
u.s southern border has put the biden
administration in the exact place it's
tried to avoid knee-deep in immigration
politics i think that's completely
accurate
in the past 24 hours the white house has
responded to images and videos of
aggressive tactics used by border patrol
to corral migrants by supporting an
internal investigation into the matter
what it hasn't done yet is figure out a
solution to the crowding and sanitary
issues arising in what's become a
makeshift encampment or stop its policy
of deporting migrants upon arrival
that's left the president and his team
with few supporters and allies and
we can talk about what should be done
while also recognizing that
in terms of biden taking heat there's
almost really nothing he could do right
you criticize the treatment of the
migrants by border patrol and the right
says oh look you're on the side of the
illegals
rather than of law enforcement and then
you do deportations and the left says
well but if we're acknowledging that
these people aren't being treated
correctly then you just send them out
back to the situation that is a disaster
in their country uh
that that's also bad and that's inhumane
and you don't improve the situation at
the encampment and that's inhumane but
if you do improve it then the right says
you're coddling criminals as they like
to say so
i get that no matter what there would be
criticism and yet we can still talk
about what is the correct path forward
which we which we will do
the article in politico goes on to say a
coalition of more than 38 civil rights
and immigrant advocacy leaders sent the
white house a letter calling on biden to
stop expulsion some of whom arrived to
the border community after fleeing
violent and natural violence and natural
disaster in their home country the
letter marks a final straw said nana
giamfi executive director of the black
alliance for just immigration
um
described the moment as an inflection
point for biden's commitment to a humane
immigration policy
members of the president's own party
including chuck schumer echoed the call
to end expulsions increasingly they did
so while directing their ire at the
white house for its handling of the
situation
12 house dems uh will hold a press
conference
calling on biden to halt deportations so
what is it that should be done here uh
it's not totally clear but it's causing
a problem for joe biden whose approval
rating has now hit a new low of 43 as of
yesterday
kamala harris down to 49
uh this is the lowest approval rating
that joe biden has had and this does not
yet fully account for what's going on at
the border with the haitian migrants
this uh poll ended on september 17th and
it has joe biden down to a presidency
low of 43 percent now it is typical
that presidents see approval
decline
throughout their presidency as we've
talked about before many people just as
soon as the president does one thing
they don't like
they say i no longer approve
and it's often difficult to change that
we've seen that with many presidents
at the same time there is a question
here about whether joe biden drops into
the 30s
and my expectation my prediction was as
we saw the approval rating start to go
down around the afghanistan situation
which i i agree with leaving afghanistan
as just as a reminder if you've not seen
those segments my thought was it'll get
down into the low 40s before it might
turn around and start going up i don't
think the situation uh in del rio is uh
going to help so what should happen you
know it seems as though
a sort of balanced approach here would
be
um
provide
better conditions and sanitation figure
out a way to do it the right will say
you're being soft but remember the
right's been saying that since january
22nd
before joe biden changed anything about
what was being done at the border
the right was already saying joe biden
is being soft
so either way they're going to say that
materially improve the sanitation
situation at the border must do there's
food shortages etc
uh do
some kind of a temporary pause on the
expulsions now the right will say these
people are here illegally so of course
you're going to deport them at and at a
certain point this is going to have to
be adjudicated in a more serious way but
the problem is if you don't put a pause
here you don't even allow the
opportunity to say
is there a valid case for asylum here
now many of us would say obviously there
is look at the situation in haiti
it's a legal question but if you just
immediately do the expulsions you don't
even allow the opportunity to do that
you're not going to please the right
that's the reality but at this point
nobody's happy with how this is being
handled and i think the the major
criticism is it seems aimless where it's
not really clear
what is even the goal
uh down there and so we will see if in
the i think by monday there has to be
some clear messaging and we may even get
it today from jen saki who's going to be
by the time you listen or watch today
the press briefing will likely already
have been held
one of our sponsors is magic spoon
breakfast cereal sweet and tasty like
the cereals i loved as a kid but without
the sugar or the carbs every serving of
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar only
four net carbs 140 calories and packed
with 13 grams of protein perfect if
you're doing keto perfect if you're
doing low carb great if you're just
trying to reduce your excess sugar
intake and because it's packed with
protein it's great before or after a
workout magic spoon flavors include
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
blueberry and cinnamon they're bringing
back cookies and cream they're bringing
back maple waffle you can build your own
variety box and try them all magic spoon
is so confident in the product if you
don't love it as much as i do they will
refund your money no questions asked go
to magicspoon.com pacman the link is
underneath this video and you'll get
five dollars off when you use the promo
code pacman at checkout